over that and across the D such a
venture emerge to see if young man trap
they and conquer we have finally come to
Ottawa and the hostel is a jail cell and
we get free tall around the jail and
everything and I'm hoping that it's
haunted
oh I'm just gonna say it's haunted just
for my own happiness morbid happiness I
guess but ya know it sounds really cool
and I will show you the building look in
jail Laura please confirm to our viewers
what you just found out about the jail
hostel that we're staying out for two
nights
its first to be haunted and what were
you telling me before we got here that I
was pretending it wasn't and what were
you telling me that they wasn't hah it's
ottawa's only haunted jail bar
downstairs so only the jail is haunted
not the cells we're in the jail oh yeah
hi guys so we woken up from my first
night in the haunted jail hostel and we
have survived no ghost footage yet but
we still have one night in hostel so you
never know what's gonna happen this
morning for everyone that stays at the
hostel you get a free tour around the
jail to death row and places like that
so that's what we're gonna do
a lot of people stay in this hospital
because they're like super captivity you
will say that we used to have a thing to
wear if you stayed in one of these cells
on death row and if you lost it the
whole night there your your stay would
be free we ended up getting rid of that
like sort of deal because no one ever
lost them tonight
Laurie just went to the toilet on her
own and came back saying that hauntings
were happening that mean words I was
like washing my hands no I was imagining
wins the hand from horn and black like
hitting the window behind me
so today the plan is to just explore
Ottawa we're going to the museum's and
trying poutine it looks fine lovely it's
gonna be really interesting
fever tell so that our last night dad
and the haunted jail cell unfortunately
there was no ghost spotted which is kind
of disappointing but I'm sure we'll live
and now we're off to Algonquin Park
which only has two hundred people living
there so this is gonna be interesting
Oh which only has two hundred people
living in the town this is gonna be
interesting
now we're gonna get on the CN Tower